all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
I have a special very special guest with
me he is a photographer some considered
one of the best photographers in the
world he is an entrepreneur launched an
amazing company called creative life you
can check it out creative lab comm we
link it up below it started off just
trying to help photographers learn how
to set their business up and I was
expanded to other creatives and
entrepreneurs and giving them the tools
they need and education need to succeed
tons of free classes and also paid ones
on there too and he's a creator of one
of the only business YouTube channels
that I subscribe to
I made a accidental guest cameo
appearance on it once - in the in the
Seattle Airport kind of randomly and the
you started the a series of web series
called the 3ds of genius which if you
guys haven't seen it's much must watch
YouTube content for all you
entrepreneurs who want to be
entrepreneurs out there I highly
recommend checking it out I warn you
though you're going to be sad when it's
over it's going to be a void in your
heart that you have to go out and now
find something new to get inspired by
mr. Chase Jarvis welcome aboard man
thank you so much for having me Evan
that was a really funny moment to bump
into you at the Seattle Airport I I just
happen to be blogging for the folks at
home I was just I was vlogging on my
iPhone camera the flight had been
delayed and I knew the travel lot so I
knew the gate agent she's like oh Jay
squirt and I was joking around with her
and then you walked up and is like hey
you're chase I was like we had a nice
little moment there it was great to see
you made it into vlogging it's fun to be
in your channel now thanks a lot yeah it
was a cool moment I was just heading I
was doing the deal with Microsoft and
just heading back to Toronto and I guess
you were on your way like a gate over on
your way to San Francisco so it was a
good little happy moment there um so you
know at that time I was watching a
YouTube channel and I was a fan and I'm
not into photography it's not really my
thing and so I watched most of your
videos the ones that were like heavy on
the gear you know wasn't really my thing
but I love all the business advice
you're giving in the behind-the-scenes
and the vlogs and all that and that's
why I like I said high end of what
you're doing and then then you like then
you drop the bomb
you bomb the 30 days of genius and it's
like now it's like must watch YouTube
and I'm tuning in I watched every
episode they're all amazing and you can
tell like your curiosity and the
questions you ask and I mean it must
have been a lot of fun for you doing
that series - I'm wondering what like
what inspired that series for you to
want to take that leap
is a big change from what you're doing
already on your YouTube channel sure I
think in order to understand the 30 days
of genius it sort of deconstructing my
world as important the curiosity is at
the core of what I think you know
amazing you know where creativity comes
from and actually work great
entrepreneurship comes from as well it's
the desire to solve problems ideally
your problems things that that challenge
you so that when stuff gets hard and it
always does building businesses or lives
that you want that you have energy and
motivation to push through those hard
times and that's why you work on your
problems and the problems of your
clothes you know posse of friends as
opposed to some other random market
opportunity and so in the process of
becoming a photographer and director and
and building an audience and getting to
work for many of the world's top brands
and doing so I really realized that
people were so much the key that we're
unlocking things for me people that I
would you know randomly meet and and I
had the good fortune of building up a a
great career in that space and one of
the things that I didn't know that I do
now and I'm trying to share is that at
the at the apex are at the top of a lot
of different industries people in
industries are friends with other people
in the in other industries at their sort
of their same peer level and when I
started you know photographing
celebrities and learning from other you
know world-class entrepreneurs just
because they were became to be in my
friend circle I was like God how can we
start to share these secrets and so back
in 2011 I developed a web series called
Chase Jarvis live where I'd sit down
with people that were really
inspirational to me and have this is
before podcasting was big you know and I
record an hour and a half long shadow
and it's beautifully shot so black and
white all in HD multiple cameras which
stream it live and we you know have
really big audiences
started putting those on YouTube and so
when my life got really busy and chaotic
probably about two years ago it's always
been you know it's always been a hustle
on a grind but I took a little bit of a
break from that series thinking about
how could I reinvent it but at the next
level and you know over the course of
those two years I had become you know
become friends with some folks that I
was excited to have on the show and I
thought what would be different maybe we
can just package all these up in like a
knowledge bomb and so I spent 45 days
interviewing 30 people who you know
again Richard Branson Mark Cuban are in
Huffington jared leto Caterina fake
found her Flickr um it just was an
insane posse of people that I was
running around with and I just wanted to
put them in one place so you could press
one button and if you go to creative
live.com slash genius you push one
button and then you get all 30 of these
interviews for free and it was when I
was flying around doing that web series
is when I bumped into you so the idea
was always there it was always a part of
my ecosystem trying to share the secrets
and sequences a little bit weird because
I don't know if they're all secrets but
when you start to when you listen to so
many people who have built amazing lives
and careers that they love there's a lot
of common threads and I wanted to sort
of surface those common threads for that
anyone who wanted to sort of tap into
that for themselves
I love it well well I speaking on behalf
of entrepreneurs it is a great service
to the community as was the the the
Jarvis live stuff that I mean that was
all amazing to when the garyvee like
back in the day and Chris Hallum like
all those old-school ones are fantastic
to watch - um I'm curious and there are
a lot of threads that come up and a lot
of out of your curiosity of people's
routines and their mindset their beliefs
I'm curious from you sitting down with
these guys what what did you learn
either like that cemented an intuition
that you already had because you heard
it so many times with people or
something view that was not really on
your radar that now you start acting it
thinking a little bit differently from
going through all these interviews gosh
it's a great question
I think if I'm just like 3 a.m. sitting
in your bed all by yourself honest it is
that there's this very powerful thing
inside all of us and particularly that
you know using as you suggested those 30
people as an example there's this a
belief in your intuition a like I have
the answers in here sure I knew I should
look for other things out in the world
for you know market ideas and things
like that but things that I care about
that I'm willing to push through and
stuff gets hard problems that I want to
solve and the way that I think the world
should be when you start to think about
what you know no one trusts what you
have inside of you I feel like that's a
you're going to hear so much negativity
in so many knows there's always a reason
not to do something but each of the
people in 30 days of genius they had
this very strong sense and sometimes
they didn't always have it they had to
work to develop it sense of what they
wanted the world to look like and and I
know your jobs fan I can see him over
your right shoulder right there on the
wall behind you Steve Jobs said that the
things around us these were invented by
nobody you know this remote control
these records TV they were all invented
by someone no smarter than you are and
they're just people who decided that
they were going to make the world in the
shape that they wanted it to be in
rather than be a cork in the tide of the
world that everyone creates around and
that was a very common thread in 30 days
of genius as the willingness to sort of
take chances and try and shape your
world rather than be shaped I love it I
love that clip to that that jobs clip
was awesome and it's actually in my mind
like my music playlist that it pops up
every now and then just as a reminder um
what so to that topic of intuition we've
had people in the chat talking about
some of the things that they want to do
what they're afraid I'm wondering for
you how did you maybe like in the
earliest days because it's a muscle that
you build and you start getting used to
witness as
it works out then it's easy to trust it
again but in those early days when
you're not sharing your pressures and
bills and family may not support you and
all you know all that stuff that hog
refers and artists and creators have to
go to how do you for that first time get
the confidence to trust the intuition
muscle well first of all it's important
to note that we all have those things
and even people that you look look at
and say Mike there's no way that person
has a fearful bone in their body hmm
people are either so ego driven or so
like willing to do whatever it takes
that is a learned behavior that is not
something that you just walk out first
yeah whatever sixth grade with it's
something that you get to you get
comfortable with and then you know so
the follow on is well then how do you
get comfortable and for me and again a
pattern that I saw and you know friends
like you know Tim Ferriss and Gary Vee
and and Swiss Miss and others was that
they started small there was the the
risks were small and you got comfortable
with putting yourself out there you know
for Gary Vee was selling baseball cards
and sit there and he'd you know try and
hustle someone for an extra 50 bucks on
this you know this I don't know a Ron
Jaworski card from nineteen you know 78
or something and and then you learn
about you know the dynamic between fear
and being rejected and being accepted
and I you do that enough times in a low
weight circumstance and you can get
comfortable for me it was the same way
it started out like putting out sharing
with photographs and saying yep first of
all when everyone else around me I
dropped at a medical school build on a
career in professional soccer and
dropped out of a PhD in philosophy to
become a photographer if you don't think
my parents were just totally like
freaked out by that you're crazy you
know they were and and yet the first
step was like actually calling myself a
photographer saying that I wanted to do
this and that was a big you know
overcoming a bunch of fear there what
when you think about like what's the
real fear well I'm probably not gonna
you know
shunned from just saying I want to be a
photographer so I said it quietly at
first and a little bit louder and then I
started showing pictures and then one
picture into picture and you can see
without me explicate awhole you know the
whole timeline how you could literally
develop the muscle as you refer to it as
so starting small failing on the regular
achieving some degree of success even if
it's only amongst your peer group and
then trying to expand that and that's
where the 10,000 hours comes from that
you've all heard about it's because you
have to develop that muscle over so much
time that that's where that it's that's
10,000 hours of not just mastering your
craft but being willing to put it out
there for for the people who have gotten
past that first step and have started to
become a photographer or a painter or
whatever creative turn or build a
business right right entrepreneur for
the people that have done that but then
can't really get their foothold in how
do you go so like moving to that next
step of being a photographer and calling
yourself Otago Ferrand like maybe
getting your first paint gigs it made me
get enough just to pay the internet
bills and you know mac and cheese and
whatever to get to the point where you
are being you know recognized worldwide
and winning winning awards and being at
the top of your field what are the
lessons that you think need to be
applied is it just mastering your craft
is it differentiate yourself is it just
working harder how does how does
somebody become the next Chase Jarvis of
their feel I think it I love the
question because I do look at those as
different things one like stress finding
that stress muscle and realizing that
you know that's how muscles like
literally muscles grows from stressing
and sort of you got to break them down
to make them stronger
so once you can get through that initial
phase that we just discussed the next
phase it very much is around I think I
can Center on one thing for me and
that's assuming you great at your craft
that you flex your muscles enough to to
be recognized as you have mastery of the
thing that at that point it becomes how
can you be different not just better and
whether that's the way you see the world
whether that's
project that you're working on whether
it's what your aspirations
like let's tech talk about Travis from
uber he's a friend and he came to me we
need had some initial success in San
Francisco and they said I want to you
know the service to Seattle can you help
me introduce some people and I was like
I didn't know you're working on like
talk to me about it but and the
capability the capacity for thinking
different and thinking big was so clear
with Travis that it's there's sort of
this desire to want to be a part of that
movement and in order to you know you've
probably heard this saying also that
it's hard to get where you're going if
you don't know where you want to go
right if you just walk in the woods you
know you if you don't have a destination
it's probably you know you're not going
to arrive at that destination so it is a
matter of how can I you know and also
the Apple slogan think different like it
really is about different and standing
out standing out is one way thinking big
is another way that's why I collapse it
all into how do you be different not
just better because at the very top pro
golfers or like musicianship the the
difference between the best and the next
best is like you can't even measure it
but who's doing their own thing who has
a vision that's radically different and
they see the world tour lens that no one
else sees that is what people can notice
and say oh my gosh I had a vision of you
know one of the things I did was create
the first iPhone app that shared photos
to social networks was called best
camera you know a year and a half before
Instagram and path and all that stuff
and it was radical for me as a
professional photographer glad you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars in gear
and traveled all over the world for the
apples and the Nikes to take pictures to
say I believe in this device this iPhone
to take pictures because it's the best
camera is the one that's with you and
that was radical so that was that was a
different thing and I think the same
thing applies to the folks at home what
is it that you really care about and
what's a lens that you have on the world
that come from in here that is different
how would you articulate the Chase
Jarvis difference because at the top of
the field like there may be guys for
even better technical
trained and you know then you do then
you are but you stood out you you one
where the guys didn't or they just mold
they just meld into each other because
they're all the same
I know it's hard because it's a creative
thing but how do you express that the
Chase Jarvis difference I think well
maybe we can just look at a couple of
the milestones and then extrapolate some
things I don't know just as a road
answer I don't have it but for example
with photography it for me wasn't just
about bringing the photic craft of
photography to life it was doing it and
for me my interest at that time was in
action sports photography I was you know
skate surf snowboard and so to take
pictures and document that culture
myself and my peers doing some of the
most radical things like all my friends
invented all the [ __ ] that we see on TV
now wingsuit jumping BASE jumping you
know first descents in Alaska jumping
out of helicopters those were things
that were that I was a part of that
movement and I know there weren't too
many people who knew how to use a camera
that could go and document that thing so
that was again a very personal
experience that I was having and I
brought the craft of photography to it
so that allowed me to be different in
photography and then I started thinking
about you know the the the phone and how
and how that could be thought of as the
fact that you always had this camera
with you and that was totally radical no
one I mean this was when I started
taking pictures with this thing in my
before that it was my Palm Pilot and
before that was my razor flip phone like
what
wait a minute that you think this is
interesting and to me it was fascinating
because you thought that as a
photographer you'd be bringing you know
what's the fanciest new camera but the
fact that you always have this with you
to me was something that was fully
different and sure enough I stood out
and that allowed me to tap into
photography plus technology and
community because this is the way that I
was able to scale community and then the
same thing as true as we move forward to
think about creative lives there were
education platforms starting on the
internet but none of them were giving
their stuff away for free it was all
behind a paywall that's why we developed
this revolutionary business model where
anyone in the world could watch for free
while
we were making the content live and you
only had to buy the content if you
wanted any time access to it and so we
were having classes that had a hundred
and fifty thousand people and Wow like
yeah you know the literally the world's
largest classes because we had this open
access freemium model and all of those
were a piece of my DNA plus some idea
that was radically different from what
the status quo was at the time so if you
look at those three things as a couple
of milestones I think it is you know
what I don't what I would I stand for is
sort of disrupting the status quo in
whatever the thing is that I'm
interested in if you know in action
sports it was bringing a camera where
the cameras hadn't been before and
technology was using a tool that hasn't
been used to express oneself and with
creative live it's providing access to
the world's top experts basically for
free there's a little business model in
there but who does that who connects
Jared Leto with you know millions of
people all over the world because you
think you should have access to the
knowledge that's insurance head so I
don't know I think it's just this
passion for you know flying in the face
of of whatever the status quo is maybe I
like it
and also not like boxing yourself in to
say hey I'm a photographer you know like
what kind of photographer goes out and
creates this educational company right
it's been it's a very very interesting
pathway for me personally like on this
journey as soon as I figured something
out I think there's a couple of nuggets
that I also saw in 30 days of genius and
it's everybody who I admired recognized
and understood that they were a - and so
as you just said ICO I used to identify
as a photographer you know then I
started becoming a director and then I
was a software developer and then I was
an entrepreneur and now I'm you know a
speaker and an advisor and an investor
and so we're all a bunch of hyphens and
I saw that as a common theme across the
30 days of genius people and then when I
deconstructed
that just you know alone my 3:00 a.m.
head like they all went really deep in
one thing that's where they spent their
10,000 hours becoming world class and
then what they did is they deconstructed
what it took
what were the common things in being
great at this thing and it's on the
whole you can apply those sort of
across-the-board to many other things
it's not on a tactical basis but on a
conceptual strategic basis you know you
they say it's all who you know it's not
what you know well that's not the case
because you have to know a lot but
knowing people who are doing amazing
stuff and your industry is absolutely
critical to becoming great in that
industry so if you're the average of the
five people you spend the most time with
you better start spending your time with
some quality people like that was a
really common theme so I like I think
you know that's probably a fair way of
looking at a you know what distinguish
me from my peers and be how can the
folks at home apply it to their own
world get great at a thing and because
you're never going to be able to move
all the balls forward all the time so
focus a little bit but then God we are
all so many different things you know we
are we and you don't have to any longer
go to work for one company get the gold
watch forty years later that's not how
it is
right and I think you said this maybe
every episode of motor of the show of
was that our parents had one job for
their lives and we have five jobs in the
next generations five jobs all at once
so I guess five or ten there's something
like that got it
yeah you can tell I am watched I watched
oh man so yeah they're beautiful yeah
and I think it's I think it's good to
have a hard time explaining what you do
like if somebody asks you what do you do
when and you can just nail it I think
you're not really living enough that
should be a terrible question true it's
true and and I think you know having an
answer that has some intrigue because
you can't not intrigued because like I'm
a basket weaving snake charmer it but
having an interest because there is like
it's it's real you're not
sort of the rote answer to me that's
there's also a value in there and that's
there's some there's integrity and
honesty that underpinning that yeah and
and I think that's just an indication of
where we're going for sure not where
we've been right so 30 days is over you
know as I said you left a huge crater
now void of content uh are you alright
like this is going to come back is there
something you want to drop to you know
give us some hope that there's more
content coming you know give us a little
bit of fuel what's next it's coming
you're sure uh so that is that that 30
days of genius series is part of the the
Chase Jarvis live show that's been going
on for years and now that's all produced
by creative life so basically I'm going
to keep doing these shows that it's a
podcast now so you can go to iTunes comm
slash Chase Jarvis and subscribe and all
of the videos that are at creative
live.com slash genius are available be a
podcast but you're going to see more of
those an increased frequency and I think
most importantly is a lot of the
concepts that are like that's like the
way your palate like oh my gosh I now I
know how Branson did this or or you know
Gary Vee did that or in Huffington did
the other thing and that creative live
there's a platform of 10,000 hours of
educational content by people like by
those people and other creators like
them at that level who have actually
done the work where you can go in act
and learn the skills that you'll be
teased with in the the chase term is
live interviews these sort of long-form
interviews with amazing amazing people
all right don't get it I'm gonna look at
I got my eye field
actually I should be - of text I was
asking my team to set up a special
discount for your viewers okay where
they could tap into creativeLIVE and I
got them a 25% off if they go to
creative live.com I think it's slash
Evan okay great
Evan I want to check that out real quick
here maybe unless you're on a computer
you can type it up my back rom slash
yeah n we don't have that linked up but
I'll make sure to add it to the notes
after for people to want to check it out
okay so other link then let me know to
what we'll that's it
creative live.com slash admin lowercase
or uppercase e lowercase I think it'll
work with anything I try to lace it okay
okay okay cool well I appreciate that
I'm gonna check it out two hours so
you've got a bunch of fans already we
got you know a live audience here and
people know you and watch a show and you
got some mega fans and some new fans so
I want to address some of their
questions Karl is writing in about
creativeLIVE I would love to know what
talent categories and types of content
you're working and looking for right now
crayon kiddo isn't content yeah right
now if you go to creative lab today we
operate in in five what we call channels
photo video art design music and audio
craft and maker and money in life now
money in life is big basically the
ability to have a living in a life and
any one of those things so it's business
and personal health development things
like public speaking leadership all that
stuff so we feel like we've got our
hands tied and a lot of work cut out for
us just focused on being the best in the
world at those in each of those
categories the the reality is is there's
so many subtleties in there there's you
know hundreds if not thousands of hours
of content underneath each of those
channels and and you know more than
25,000 lessons so the reality is we are
focused on those things and yet at the
same time there's so many things like
health and wellness and yoga and all
that stuff that's embedded in that money
in life category so when we think about
talent and we think about where our
focus is it's it's in those channels and
I don't see a change in anytime in the
near future because we had a lot of work
to still right is there anything within
those sub channels that you've
you feel like I'd love to get this type
of content addressed mmm
we're doing a lot with video because
videos as we know it's just such a
powerful and always emerging medium a
lot of social like how to use video for
building brands and whether it's
personal brands or business brands and a
lot of the softer skills like the
emotional intelligence like body
language and stuff like that those are
areas where we're going to continue to
invest I think we're the best in the
world the best place in the world to get
an education and photography rapidly
achieving that in design we just had
Debbie Millman we've had Stefan
Sagmeister we've got Michael Beirut in
the next couple of weeks like these are
just this is like the the Michael
Jordan's the the the best of the best in
those categories
and yet we're like we're just getting
started and money in life and that's
where folks like Tim Ferriss and Ryan
holiday and Kelly Starrett other folks
who have big YouTube followings and
whatnot that's where their content is
living I think that is an area of growth
for us for sure cool
like I like YouTube stuff I'm gonna keep
my my eyes open i CML I'll do I'll drop
one other nugget here which is I've just
well basically Starbucks is underwriting
a series of documentaries that I'm
making and the series is called uploaded
and if you go to to youtube.com slash
double-shot that's basically I just
launched the first one another one drops
on Saturday another one drops the
following Saturday and it looks like
that series is likely going to continue
and these are with people have millions
of youtube subscribers and it's their
story arc about everyone who told them
no and how they couldn't do it and and
so there's a lot in there in those
little documentaries about personal
brand about overcoming obstacles about
the world is going to tell you that your
dream isn't good enough or it's too big
or not big enough it's too square knot
Square enough it's too racing you're not
racy enough you're going to get all this
feedback and you see that these through
lines of
just overcoming these obstacles it's a
powerful thing so check that out - it's
it's worthy of a subscribe but think I
know where if you're like me you're very
um you're very precious with subscribing
because we want to keep that Sigma noise
ratio low I believe this will add value
to you guys lives so where am I going
for this one what it's stuffs are
bugging you yeah it's a YouTube channel
that we just started for Starbucks
called youtube.com / double shot double
shot okay I bet you tied into our next
question
great let's follow up those from Jay
Rhys Evan has a photo of Howard Schultz
in his wall
that's true this is mr. Starbucks right
there and chase seems to have hooked up
with Starbucks double-shot for uploaded
that this time really well here uh how
did that Starbucks collab come to life
great great question so a friend of mine
Jason owns an ad agency called mechanism
mechanism with a K incredible agency
they do they work everybody from the
White House to the biggest brands every
Super Bowl commercials and they have an
influencer network called epic signal
that another friend of my Brendon
started and it's sort of like an agency
within an agency and one of my favorite
things about about this sort of the new
world order where we can all sort of you
know pursue our passions and whatnot is
when you do that then you achieve some
some level of recognition people call
you the phone rings and so the phone
rings and you develop relationships and
this relationship I have with epic and
mechanism they're often getting pitched
or pitching different brands on concepts
Starbucks came to them and said we'd
love to do something within YouTube
community and around storytelling and so
immediately mechanism and epic reached
out and said you know you're a host you
know I basically host things - given
that I've sat down interviewed so many
you know world-class people I enjoy that
very much and they said God you have
that guide you have thats
hmm so you know would you be interested
in hosting and directing this series so
they put us together and I will you know
I really applaud brands that put that
invest money into creators to create
things that will add value to the
community because we you know as a
career-long photographer and director
people pay me to create some advertising
asset for them you know a photograph
that shows someone sipping a nice cup of
coffee but this new world order and I
really got to give Starbucks you know
shout out for this
they're like chase but here here's some
money go tell stories that inspire other
people to follow their dreams and we're
just going to underwrite it and like
we're just going to like you know just
support it and of course we'll hope to
get people that think in that Starbucks
is cool because that's where otherwise
it wouldn't spend the money but they're
spending the money on inspiring and
motivating people to live the dream and
to me that's a there are so few brands
that have done that and of course it's
getting more popular but I got to give
them a shout out because it's not cheap
to do these things and it's um it's
something that where there's a lot of
passion and they have to get out of the
way you know kind of sounds like almost
a mini 30 days of genius focused on
youtubers it's it's there you go oh you
said it not me but it's very you know
and again that's like you put something
out there like I put three days of jeans
out there and people look at it like wow
what would that be like if we thought
about it through the lens of YouTube and
I'm sure that's one of the reasons that
they they contacted me so if there is
ever a question it should do work yeah
you should do work that you love doing
because that's what people are going to
see and if you want to get hired to do
that work you have to put it out there
in the world in the first place so you
want to you want to sell lemonade well
build a lemonade stand sell some
lemonade and then maybe someone else
will come along and say hey we'd like
you to sell aren't impalas we're gonna
combine lemonade and iced tea or you
know whatever but yes it is you know and
I appreciate the question from I forget
who asked it but I'm J rise yeah J rise
like these things like they're they
really come up really authentically and
it's cool when you get someone who's
willing to spend the money to support
creators you know yeah I thought I felt
fortunate to be selected for the job
have you enjoyed the transition to being
in front of the camera now oh I have I
have enjoy there is a part of my
personality if I take an Enneagram study
I don't if you've heard the iniya grams
it's like the personality traits I often
end up as performer I don't really think
of myself as someone who wants to sing
and dance but although I like those
things but I enjoy I enjoy I'm
comfortable enough in front of people
that I feel like I can help peel back
some of the layers of the onion and to
do it rather publicly whether it's my
own layers or layers that I see out in
pop culture so I look at being in front
of the camera not as an end but as a
means to helping like that's where I get
my juices by helping people live their
dreams because it was very very hard I
feel like I came from I mean middle
class lower middle class but relatively
speaking privileged you know I mean he
despite the fact that my family didn't
have a lot of money there was all kinds
of things I didn't have to overcome like
I was born into a race that has
privilege into a country were relative
to many other countries we have
privileges and so even though I was sort
of poor I don't take that for granted
for a second I try and you know stay
stay hungry and stay humble but what I
when I realized that that holy smokes if
it was hard for me to pursue my passion
because of all the social pressures and
you mentioned you know having kids and
mortgages and what you need to be in
life how hard would it be if you had all
of those things plus a bunch of other
stuff so god I need to get out there and
it's been so fulfilling to to track and
and hustle around the thing that I
wanted to be and do that I would be
great if I could give that same gift to
other
and so if I can be in front of the
camera to pursue that mission happy to
do it
I don't just aspire to get up there and
sing a dance but I'm willing to do the
work because I think it leads to a good
end Jim Collins did an awesome speech
talking about leadership and one of the
things that he said had common traits
was humbleness for the cause and that
you would do anything for the cause we
may not think of Steve Jobs as a humble
guy but he would humble himself for the
cause
so like I need this to happen I will do
whatever it takes for it to happen and a
part of that for you is like getting out
there and being in front of the camera
for sure you know whatever anxiety one
needed it's more native for me to be
back here right but I have just I've
decided to love being on the other side
and entertaining because if I can
provide an entertaining lens on pursuing
your dreams god it's given me so much
and I want you and you knew and you used
to tap into that - well whatever
whatever anxiety and rivers you have
about doing that I would encourage you
to continue because it's having an
impact and really I mean you see it on
the comments you see it the comments in
your videos and and you know it's such a
people but people waiting for your next
movement and so you can count me in
whatever it is I'm gonna check out the
double-double shot I'm gonna take that
as anything else um no he's kind of me
to check it out thank you I know what
kind of hitting up against the clock the
people watching here are kind of the
same target audience they're creatives
or entrepreneurs there are spine
entrepreneurs is there a final message
that you want to leave them with um I
would talk their ear off if I was in the
same room as them I would just keep
going but since our time is limited uh I
think that thing inside you that you
want to do that's the thing that you
should do and chances are there's a
story that you're telling yourself about
why you can't or why it's hard and if
you can step back just for a second and
whether if you're meditation or
self-awareness or actually just
listening to the words and then walking
away from this video and like things
like
really is keeping me from doing that oh
I've got a mortgage okay do I need to be
in that big house can i downsize oh it's
my kids well you're certainly not going
to like the kids aren't going to go live
on the street so can you sit down with
the family and say look at I really want
to pursue this how can we mitigate the
risk like are you are you proactively
doing those things because at the end of
the day what I found across the board
having ultimately been a career
counsellor to millions of people is that
the distance between where you are right
now and where you want to be living
whatever life that is it's much shorter
than you think it is you wake up we've
got that 3:00 a.m. crocodile brain
that's telling us how bad we're doing
and how far away everything is and how
hard everything is but if you stepped
away from that and just did an honest
assessment and wrote down as few steps
as you could the distance is always
shorter than you think it is so I don't
know about you and it seems to me like
you're living your passion and you've
created a living in a life for yourself
around this so I hope you join me in
this but I think it's fair to say that
that there are a lot of barriers between
you and that thing but as soon as you
realize that those barriers are there to
keep everybody else out it'll free you
up to go after your your dreams I love
it the barriers are there just to keep
everyone else out I like that I like I'm
going to use that and credit you back
mr. Chase Jarvis cool thank you so much
for the time thank you all you guys for
watching go check out creative live I
guess slash Evan now if you want the
discount check out the three days of
genius I will link that up and the new
double shot I'll put that in the
description too
I really appreciate your time chase guys
watching you need to believe and we'll
see you soon
thanks a lot appreciate it